in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast we are a podcast
about everything and anything and
basically you're the fly on the [ __ ]
wall and you're just listening to good
conversation with a bunch of goofy ass
people
oh no what like the first introduction
to people this is podcast like what am i
listening to who is it oh they don't see
faces because it's an audio podcast well
I'm a [ __ ] so just to let you know it's
okay and he's half cook percent Chris
she's a good you know what the [ __ ] you
did it you uh you thought this was a
Meghan but two podcast ah [ __ ]
foolish foolish child are you the genius
brain i everybody is a genius brain you
know how we came up with genius right no
i don't these brain is just sarcasm
basically somebody stupid oh yes i am a
genius brain oh okay well we have a very
special guest today her name is Amanda
soup now you may have seen her from
dancing to acting to everything else and
all of the above
oh she's a children's book [ __ ]
Arthur dude yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
Thank You Khalif you're welcome yeah
other than that she's trash okay pretty
much yeah shower today so yeah pretty
much really so nice I think that's why I
think girls can do that though girls can
go like a couple days without showering
and you guys are okay yeah guys do smell
oh wait you say we smell yeah dude all
right
Oh like in general right now oh no like
in general oh if you didn't [ __ ]
smell like yeah if you walk into a guy's
bedroom it has a distinct yes males
[ __ ] smell absolutely I don't know
what that is but I don't know why girls
the girls just don't admit that scent
like you said your guys's room smells
super [ __ ] nice yeah yeah like even
if I didn't clean for five days it still
would probably smell better than a guys
oh for sure for sure 100% I think you
guys like Baskin you're you're gassy
sense like you guys don't care oh I do
care
do you like I have scented candles
everywhere yeah well yeah you don't
particularly smell but I have smelled
your farts before have you
yeah oh really yeah I farted pretty
before yes you have maybe huh that's
tight dude it was so bad that she
remembers it but I don't she [ __ ]
grew a couple of gray hairs for me to
[ __ ] er yeah so have you been oh yeah I
haven't seen you in a while huh I think
in a [ __ ] long time dude
how long has been the last time I saw
you we got food and I ate spam for the
first time in ages with you is what
happened I'm like I said earlier good
and okay I don't know what that means
what you be good at okay I feel every
time I talk to you you have like some
kind of like emotional turmoil I think
that's a life artist there's always
something going what the [ __ ] is going
on with you it's because I am constantly
in tune with my emotion so if I'm real
with myself then I know and I'm
reflective of what's really going on as
opposed to just being like oh yeah
everything's like gravy okay does that
mean you psychopath what's going on well
I really didn't know what I was walking
into so I was not prepared for this you
told me that there's gonna be a topic no
no no I didn't there's never topics here
what this is cherry we just talked we
just chopped it up I just want to see
what's going on in your life but you
came in today saying that you were good
and he went from I'm great I'm okay well
I didn't say great I said good I'm good
no I'm okay so what's going on
oh no I mean just today I was a little
down on myself about what um I think I
feel a little like things aren't moving
at the pace that I would like them to
move but that happens every other day in
terms of where my career career life
love finances adult teachers everybody
in LA yes artists in LA for sure
no but otherwise I'm good because I
think 2019 engine
has been a much more healthier year for
me
whereas last year I I was kind of stuck
in a lot of I was struggling with a lot
of depression anxiety and I think this
year it's been healthier in the sense
that I've been practicing more
disciplined habits like what well I read
this book called miracle morning and it
challenges you to wake up two hours
earlier than you normally wake up so in
the book the author talks about how he
wakes up every day at 5:00 a.m. mm-hmm
and then he does he has like a hour like
habitual practice he does before he even
gets ready to go out for the day so he
spends his first hour in like writing
and meditation and exercise and a bunch
of other stuff and so I did that for 30
days and I I did 6 a.m. for 30 days and
that actually really really helped and
it was even during a super busy month
for me but I stuck to it with some like
give and take because you still do that
now I don't wake up at 6 a.m. anymore
but I still the first hour of my day I
still practice on like reading
meditating writing and journaling and
all that before I obviously you're
pretty disciplined for somebody who's
like in like terms of arts because I
can't [ __ ] do that like I've I've
told myself that I was gonna learn how
to speak Japanese it's been 30 years
like I haven't like I have a didi when
it comes to learning new things like I
get really really excited about learning
new things and then I'll work on it
hardcore for like two weeks and then my
brain just like the next thing like I
told myself I was gonna learn ASL and I
know sign language American Sign
Language why I just well I I wanted to
learn I felt like I've always want to
learn another language but I felt like
ASL might be easier for me because it
kind of be like choreography so like
dancing I thought it's just so random
because I was like oh do you know
somebody there was there are a couple
people at my church that are that are
deaf and I've just wanted to be able to
communicate with them without having to
use an interpreter which obviously I'm
still gonna use the interpreter
I'm not fluent but I wanted to at least
show them that like someone is making an
effort to like make them feel included
in the community I guess but then I also
just thought it'd be really cool to just
know another language and then I got
distracted and then I got into like
fighting techniques so I hit up a friend
of mine you know Yoshi right yeah I
bring him in I trade with him but we do
Muay Thai together oh yeah that's right
yeah so him and Brandon sue they both
helped me out because I wanted to get
better with bo staff fighting and so
they were training me for a couple of
weeks that was for a job but then I got
actually into it so now I'm I'm actually
gonna try to meet up with Yoshi on
Thursday and I'm gonna try to continue
fight training but hopefully I can stick
to it as opposed to burn out like after
a month and then move on to well I mean
I feel like I'm you seem to be somebody
that's just like are you somebody who
just like continually gets into like
random hobbies all the time yeah I think
because I like learning new things but
then I just suck at sticking to it
there's a lot of people though but I
think I like that though I like getting
into random things and even if I drop it
it doesn't really matter because this is
more about the experience at the end
yeah I mean just because like life is
short dude I mean you never you're not
gonna know what you dislike unless you
try it first true so I just have like
basic knowledge and a lot of random
things as opposed to being like really
bomb at one thing over you I mean the
last time I talked to you where we were
we a that costume party hmm I had the
spam that's where you had this bang yeah
that's right hadn't had spam in like six
years and then that happened that I was
like dang it I guess man just health
challenges sucked did you like it yeah
dude yeah dude I missed it I trust David
so when it comes to food I hope so
that's my [ __ ] I love that place man so
you know because like I mean the last
time I talked to you you were kind of
going through a lot of emotional [ __ ]
like in terms of like where you expected
yourself to be and where you wanted to
be in life and like how I mean how do
you have you been managing that uh gosh
when okay that was last year I think
when I met up with you I was going
through some [ __ ] yeah I was deaf
in the thick of my depression and like I
think I kind of really started to hit
the the thick of it the rock bottom of
it towards the end of 2018 and I don't
know what I went on a hike with a friend
and she's the one that gave me this book
the miracle morning book and I think
that just kind of snapped me out of it
because I I just needed something to
focus on I guess in terms of what is in
my control because acting stuff that's
like once you do the work and go in and
audition everything else after that is
so out of your hands so like that would
get really frustrating that like I
constantly felt like I couldn't do more
after a certain point you know what I
mean because like you do what you do and
then you just have to move on to the
next thing yeah cuz that's like the the
hard part I think like when you talk
about stuff where you say I wish when
you get down on yourself and you kind of
wish that you were somewhere that you
expected yourself to be at a certain
timeline and those things just never
work out like you just you just can't
because you could always tell yourself
that you want something to happen right
then and right now but sometimes fate
just says [ __ ] you and you just got to
deal with it absolutely that's just
that's just like your life I thought I
was gonna at 18 I thought I was gonna be
like some kind of like music star I
don't know why music cuz I just
auditioned for something I fell flat on
my face like I that was the most nervous
I've ever been cuz I had my sheet music
in front of me and you could literally
see my hand shaking you know that that
feeling of like and if you're watching
someone and you see them that nervous
and you see them shaking it's how your
heart breaks for them yeah
like I didn't have my my song memorized
so so I was looking down at the sheet
music so I'm looking at the paper
shaking I'm like oh no I'm that girl
right now it was just making it worse
what was this for well I guess I could
talk about it now because it's been
announced but I auditioned for ABC is
doing a live musical of a little mermaid
Oh in addition to its separate from the
live-action movie that Disney's making I
think it's because it's supposed to be
celebrating the anniversary I think it's
like maybe 30 you know that's - I forget
how many yeah whatever year anniversary
of the little boy who are you
auditioning for one of arias sisters oh
and we had to sing the daughters of
Triton song
don't know if you remember that it was
really embarrassing and I knew someone
that was on the casting side and as soon
as I saw her when I walked in I was like
[ __ ]
I hate auditioning in front of people I
know because then you really can't do it
and then leave and not think about like
Oh what did that person the person that
was on the casting hard of casting yeah
and so that just like made me more
nervous because if it's people you don't
know then it's like whatever cuz I'm
never gonna see them again but then this
person I'm like how do you fall flat on
your face I was so nervous I was shaking
and I couldn't breathe and I was just
like I haven't really thought she fell
on her face I'm great at singing in my
shower
everybody ya know but then like and like
we were miked up and I was like oh no
now I also have to listen to myself did
you have to sing it it was just you
though right yeah well me and then like
everyone in there's an accompanist
there's the girl that was like the whole
shabang shabang yeah and it was rough
off-key would you flat was going on all
the above I was probably all of those
things I think I hit one note well out
of like what happened' I was just nerve
I don't know I just haven't been that
nervous and it was it was a humbling
experience because I have not been that
nervous and so long where I was shaking
nervous like I guess you've been
auditioning for quite a bit so I thought
I find that shocking I mean acting
auditions is so different I think
there's something so vulnerable that's
you know like singing there's I don't
know there's something so much more
vulnerable about singing oh yeah for
sure
I just think just cuz you're so like
you're such a veteran in the game I
thought you would just hold I don't know
how long you've been acting for five
years but like auditioning for almost
three
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] good man you
just I feel like with auditioning you
imagine just get scab the [ __ ] over man
yeah you just stopped caring at a
certain point you just walk in it's like
if you like it you like it if you don't
what [ __ ] ever did yeah I mean yeah
with acting auditions for sure I
telling you singing that was that was so
scary
that was really do your audition right
now you are Poseidon and I am Sebastian
the decidin yo you know [ __ ]
Sebastian is a crab and not a lobster
did I know this no he's a crab did you
know that in in this well they already
announced I know
Oh does he not know he doesn't know so
in the in this ABC live musical Ursula
is Queen Latifah and Sebastian is Shaggy
[Laughter]
how they got him for that cuz he like
fell off the face of the earth for like
30 years and then whoever it was like
yeah shaggy would make a great Sebastian
what the [ __ ] yeah that's crazy hmm
so there you have it you would have been
a part of that casting this is gonna be
a multicultural [ __ ] Little Mermaid
it is the girl who got cast for a Little
Mermaid is the Moana chick how do you
say her name I don't know the because
there was that whole controversy with
the whole the the the what's it what's
her name I'd actually don't know uh
where's she from she's she's pretty
well-known right because people know who
she is you her and her sister
yeah they they had a cover on YouTube
that I believe somehow made it to the
hands of Beyonce and then like Beyonce
shouted them out I don't know they just
like blew up and went viral and now then
they had like a really successful
YouTube musician career mm-hmm and then
like they even sing at the Grammys last
year I think what
yeah they got invited to sing at the
Grammys last year Kevin oh yeah and now
this girl is well one of the sisters
which I always wonder like when it's
like a duo like that like does your
sister feel jaded tell you something man
I find a brother and then we were the
singing duo and then he went off to be
[ __ ] I don't know
shang-chi the music are you trying to
say you're jealous of senior huh are you
trying to say you're jealous I don't
think anybody's jealousy he's a nice guy
we were we were we were on JK news
together I would have loved to seen a
shang-chi with you dog I would have made
the best funniest Shane she ever did for
my [ __ ] superhero powers I would be
able to stir-fry anything I'm pretty
sure there was a lot of like Asian
actors going for that [ __ ] yeah that
shang-chi [ __ ] yeah I knew I actually
personally want people they were asking
me they were like yo aren't you hiked
about shang-chi I'm like who a [ __ ] is
that dude [ __ ] shang-chi is I was
mispronouncing it the whole time I was
calling a shank I know who the [ __ ] she
was well Somchai sounds more Asian than
string cheese hi it's got a chance oh
yeah I guess so you're right like did
you know what did any [ __ ] person out
there in the [ __ ] podcast will know
who shank she was I definitely didn't
nobody knows who the [ __ ] shank she is
right so like when people are like are
you hyped about it no I'm not hyped
about it I don't [ __ ] know who shank
she is if I grew up with shang-chi I'd
be [ __ ] hype as hell this podcast was
brought to you by rake on my friends
it's 2019 and everyone needs a great
pair of wireless earbuds if you don't
have wireless earbuds what are you doing
because those wires are frickin annoying
but before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
their wireless earbuds from rake on
recon recon rake on my friends let me
tell you something
the moment I started doing these walks
every morning and I realized that I
didn't need wires dangling from my soft
beautiful supple neck I was like I need
to get me some wireless earbuds and I
got these rake on air buds rake on is
actually pretty dang don't man rake on
ear buds start at about half the price
of any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market and they sound just as
amazing the company was actually
co-founded by Ray J and celebrities like
Snoop Doggy Dogg cardi B and a whole
bunch of other people men unlike some of
your other Wireless options rake on
earbuds are both
and discreet with no dangling wires or
stems and of course they don't just look
great they sound great - I got the r8
Connie fifty son and that's what I take
on my daily walks and people always walk
up to me and they're like yo what are
those in your ear man I'm like they're
ray Connie 50 son you best know about it
and your best cop12 because I'm telling
you you're missing out on the wave son
well guess what go to buy rake on Comm
slash brain to get 15% off your order
that's buy rake on.com slash brain for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now is the
time to get an amazing deal one more
time by rake on Comm slash brain we are
you still auditioning every now and then
if I want to do audition for Shanxi I
would crack the [ __ ] up I would have
loved to have seen that thought I would
have loved to audition for that [ __ ]
because I would have done it with a
thick ass time juice but you're also how
well your fight training so like why not
well I'm not camera fight training
though I'm fight fight training though
that's different oh you're trying to
like beat some people up in real no I
don't know I just do boy type of Muay
Thai stuff isn't made for camera so it's
like it's completely different right
when when yo she comes in and trains
with us he has to get rid of all of his
camera [ __ ] and be more practical
fighting so it's a little different yeah
because when that stuff came I like
people are asking me to be hyped about
it I can't be because I don't know who
it is
well is there ever a superhero you ever
wanted to play oh of course
man I want who I want yeah [ __ ] The
Blob [ __ ] he's a villain I love
that [ __ ] no I don't really care for
that caption you know you don't care for
superhero stuff I like I don't know I
like comic books and stuff but I don't
have a urge to want to play one you know
what I mean like I don't have a
connection to it like that but I love
superhero should I grew up with like
Marvel like the whole DC Universe and
everything like that but like I talked
about this before where I never had this
idea where you know when people ask me
do you wish that there would be more
Asian superheroes well for me as a kid
when I saw superheroes I never thought
that my ethnicity was a barrier for me
to try to emulate a fake character you
know I never looked at super medicine oh
because you know I'm a time Cody and a
man I can't be Superman I'm just like no
I'll be Superman like what the [ __ ] does
that matter
also - I grew up in a very diverse area
so there wasn't a lot of white people in
my school so nobody was gonna say
otherwise I didn't really grow up with a
lot of that that type of prejudice that
other people did cuz Sacramento was just
extremely close to a diverse so I don't
I don't know what that feels like
right cuz I feel like for you did you go
brown a lot white people yes but I also
my high school is pretty divert like I
was one of four Asian people in my high
school but that being said I think I had
a bit of a weird utopian environment of
high school where I never got called out
for being Asian like nobody made me feel
like the token Asian ever yeah so it
wasn't it wasn't this thing to make of
it I just was like I would my identities
were oh she's the smart one who's also
the dancer and is in choir like those
were my Denny's not like asian chick
that's why it's hard for me to relate to
that time yeah right so it's like man I
know that a lot of people who kind of
grew up in that like I can't really
speak for them yeah I know like this is
one kid when I was in UCR what city are
you university I Riverside
alright shoutouts to this I said it like
I it like yeah I know you see our baby
[ __ ] you that school sucks they yeah
this kid was telling me about how when
he grew up like I'm talking about in San
Diego like he grew up in San Diego and
he went to like an all-white school and
like kids used to bully him make all
these Asian jokes at him like threw him
in a bush and [ __ ] like that
and I did not grow up with that so I
don't even know what the [ __ ] that
shit's like man I can't imagine like a
white guy coming up to me and going oh
yeah and I was like all right let's get
mean there's it would just be so odd I
wouldn't even be a Fed that it would
just be like whoa what's this guy do it
yeah actually don't think I like really
got any ching chong remarks until I got
to college in New York City of all
places like that's where I really felt
like I was Oh Toby you graduated from
NYU did yeah that's [ __ ] crazy I
didn't know that you you ever told me
you don't know anything about me okay
where did I graduate from [ __ ] how
about that UC Davis dad look at that you
don't know nothing bro she just came in
like I know IDR I literally just said
you see how she goes Lucy Davis started
I graduated all do trick question fine
would you that's amazing they did I did
it was the best time of my life what did
you go to NYU for oh you this this'll
trip you up I went to school for music
business Oh what is that what might us
well you trying to be an A&R oh [ __ ] I
yeah I thought that's what I wanted to
do actually my senior year I started
thinking more about music supervision
yeah but then that's such a weird world
to get into especially back then so I I
didn't get any job I mean I got a job at
ASCAP but it sucked really badly like I
cried
I mean you I think you obviously clearly
wanted to get involved with some type of
entertainment yeah hey Mia what no
matter what it was if it was behind the
scenes on it in front of the camera
we're still doing that yeah I mean I
think that was always a dream and then
everything that I've done up until this
point was like like a weird parallel to
like possibly get into the real thing
yeah except I was just always too scared
to just go into the real thing so I was
finding every kind of tangent yeah
surrounding it like even music business
my parents always joke about how the
only reason they let me go to NYU for
music business was because they only
heard business didn't hear the music
part so that's why they were like yeah I
go to NYU we'll help you out and support
you and then they're like oh music
business wait can you not change your
major like what is that about because I
didn't even get a business degree I got
a Bachelor of Music and what's that
going to do hmm how's it done anything
no are your parents okay with you being
like in the arts an actor it's been an
ongoing battle
they have come around I would say I've
had I mean what are they gonna do well
you know I mean I think if I can kill
you like they won't kill me but they
definitely have like asked me to move
back home because they don't want to do
a yeah [ __ ] Louisiana
who like st. Louis's okay er st. Louis
smooth are you from me
no hurry Louis for real how do you
people what am i from you're from
Sacramento no I've had I've had multiple
multiple talks with them and five years
ago my my mom and I got in a huge fight
and I remember I didn't talk to her for
like two weeks because she was so not on
board and I I remember she said
something really hurtful I don't think
she heard it as hurtful but she
basically said something along the lines
of like this is how I remember it
something along the lines of like I
don't think you're beautiful enough to
make it in the industry and that like I
remember I got so sad and I like
obviously like that's like the hardest
thing to hear and I remember saying
something like what are you talking
about I'm not beautiful enough to be
making in this industry I'm like your
DNA sorry basically saying you're not
beautiful this is the worst comeback
ever
but pretty bad but it's also because of
her age and number one she's Korean
yeah and she there her perception of
what an actor celebrity is is based on
those the people that she grew up
watching yeah and they based it all on
looks and there's no talent involved
well they're talented people yeah but
that was such a huge roadblock and so
for her in her mind she's just like well
you're not like this lady that I yeah
it's like okay well no and so we like
you know I didn't talk to her for a
couple weeks but then that's finally as
we I brought the conversation up again
and then she kind of explained like way
later that it was she was just speaking
out of fear cuz she just was so scared
for me to feel rejected and hurt and
blah blah blah and all these things
which you know fair enough and so we
came to this agreement she's like how
much time do you think you need to like
make it as an actor there's no time
there is none but I said five years I'll
give you five years and then like if you
know if you're not able to like fully
support yourself as an actor in five
years and you need to move home but then
we had another talk this
past year and she's I think I think
because of like booking Runaways has
helped a lot because then she got really
supportive and then she was like what is
Hulu how do I show this to everyone at
church and like you know now she's like
oh you can make money off of this so
then she's become much more supportive
since then and so she's like a little
bit more off my back and like yeah much
more supportive now and I just had to I
just needed that one job to like prove
to her like how it's not impossible I
can do this when your mom said that to
you like how did you process it
especially during that moment like what
do you how did you deal with that that's
such a pretty harsh yeah I mean I don't
think I fully believed in myself yet so
it just made it that much harder because
it's like I don't even fully believe in
myself and like I see all these friends
of mine who have like who have these
kind of traditional American families
where like the parents are like we
support your dreams like we're gonna go
to all your shows and like look this is
our baby like look how talented our kid
is and so kind of being hysterical
killers yeah you know so it evens out in
the end start shooting up like a Walmart
so [ __ ] too soon never do so
those [ __ ] look crazy dude oh
yeah no my parents I think feeling like
they didn't believe in me just I mean
that's the hardest thing as a kid to be
like your own parents don't believe that
you have what it takes so I think for a
while it got me down and then after a
while thinking about it it was like
that's what kind of made me want to work
harder yeah to prove to them and prove
to myself and then I just after a while
I was also like well it forced me to
learn how to believe in myself because
it's like alright no one no one's gonna
do it for you you you do have to be the
first person to believe in yourself so
like I'm never gonna have a career in
this industry if I don't believe in me
so it pushed me but in a painful way I
guess it's hard right because I think
like specifically for acting like you
really just have to [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] mm-hm
you really do because it's such a hard
[ __ ] choice right because
you know when you go for a job and like
a regular job I'm talking about like a
nine-to-five which is you know [ __ ]
dope whatever but at the same time like
when you have that job in that career
for whatever time spend that you're
there you're contracted for a year or
whatever you you have somewhat idea of
how long you'll be there right before
you either get fired you decide to move
to another job right with acting the
weird thing is it's just it's constant
it's never [ __ ] ending and you have
to be okay with doing this career
knowing that you just might never make
it but you're very happy doing what
you're doing yeah I mean I think that's
the thing I've I think that's one of the
things that changed this year was I
actually started becoming excited again
even when it was just an audition
because if it's a character I really
enjoyed I would go to sleep super
excited for the next day just to get to
play that character even if it was for
only like five or ten minutes no you
know and so there is a definite new kind
of excitement that's kind of awakened
this year but yeah I don't know I was
reading something earlier today actually
another Asian actor was talking about
all the Mike Mo controversy around him
playing Bruce Lee in once upon a time I
don't know he's a Asian actor he was
playing Bruce Lee and Once Upon a Time
and I think a lot of people were upset
with like the Bruce Lee portrayal in
that movie with Quentin Tarantino and
this other Asian actor was talking about
how I think a lot of people especially
who aren't actors think that we have so
much power
especially as like minority actors in
the kinds of roles we get offered and if
we do get offered a role which is like
once in a blue moon like we don't have
the kind of clout that say a Matt Damon
or you know a Brad Pitt can have in
terms of like adjusting what's being
portrayed or like the story that's being
told like we're kind of still in a place
of like we're kind of forced to just
grab what we can just even like make a
name for ourselves so that we can
eventually have the clout to do that but
we're not there yet and so like he was
talking about how like there might be a
year where you know we'll go on maybe
200 auditions he said 200 I was like if
I had 200 audition
like say 200 auditions in a year you can
expect 100% failure like 100% rejection
so the fact that like we are going out
on all these auditions and like might
get maybe one or two callbacks in an
entire year if we do and then if we did
get a role it's like yeah we're not
going to complain about like well you
know you're portraying this actor and
XYZ kind of way like we're hungry we we
need jobs like we this is we're in this
profession and we need to pay for food
on our table you know and yeah of course
it'd be nice if we could like come in
and like be like I'm so sorry like this
role is not for me because I don't agree
with it but like if we say no to
everything like we're gonna have nothing
so people were upset at at Mike what is
mike mo mike mo for being an actor I
mean essentially choice it's hard for me
to wrap my head around that because it's
just I think because I don't Bruce Lee
is sag one of those things that people
Revere so high I feel like any time
somebody touches Bruce Lee people
getting mad [ __ ] sensitive about yeah
no matter when you know like it's just
one of those weird things cuz for me
it's like are you mad at an actor for
acting out a role yeah like it's it he
wasn't I'm it's a it was like a parody
version of Bruce Lee right it wasn't
actually Bruce Lee it wasn't a
documentary it's a [ __ ] film but
maybe that's just how I see it right and
it really depends too because I know
that Bruce Lee's family specifically his
daughter is very very sensitive about
the the image of her father right
because and ibly so yeah yeah but even
then to like shout out to Sharon Shannon
Shannon I'm so sorry to Shannon Lee I
know that your father somebody that's
very important to you but there will be
a time when you pass away too and then
you know you're gonna expect people to
protect his legacy or whatever his
legacy is sentence don't people know who
Bruce Lee is Bruce Lee is they know who
he is and even if she didn't try to
defend them the rest of the world would
have they didn't like Bruce Lee is a
[ __ ] legend you know what I mean
there's this hardly a single person I
know in this world that talks ill about
Bruce Lee unless people are trying to
discredit him as a martial artist but
even then when people tried to it gets
Dober let me just tell you this real
quick there was a [ __ ] video of
Michael Jai White somebody asking
Michael Jai White I forgot who it was it
might have been [ __ ] sway or some
[ __ ] but no it was Vlad or I forgot who
it was that interview but either way
asking him Michael Jai White remind you
Michael Jai White is huge he's like six
foot what four or some [ __ ] he's a giant
just masse muscles like a 10000 degree
black belt or something and I asked him
would you be able to beat up Bruce Lee
in a fight he says of course right and
then [ __ ] the internet went crazy
they're like how dare you [ __ ] say he
would beat up Bruce Lee in a fight and
the Michael Jai White was like man I
[ __ ] up saying that not because he
doesn't believe that he could beat him
up it's just because the legacy around
Bruce Lee is so big that if you say
anything that slights his name in the
smallest microscopic way his fanbase
comes and destroys you right because if
you really think about it like this
Michael Jai White is six foot something
bigger arguably more athletic and maybe
faster and stronger than Bruce Lee who
really knows right and I might even get
[ __ ] just burned for that type of
[ __ ] but I'm just talking about from
seeing mixed martial arts growing up my
whole life you know trying to do more
type the age of 20 and seeing sighs does
[ __ ] matter and that's all Michael
Jai White was saying like he believed
him in himself as a martial artist and
he believes that size does matter and he
would be a hundred and something pounds
above Bruce Lee and that's really what
he was saying right so I think like when
it comes to that Bruce Lee topic people
get hypersensitive about it but for me
it's a film yeah it's an actor and it
was a parody version of me yeah it's
like if someone were trying to come for
BTS like those fans are rabid probably
get attacked for just calling them
routed I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys
do [ __ ] weirdos Korean I love Korean
music I'm Korean I could see where the
[ __ ] I want dude like I love Korean
music man but the way people things like
you don't ever talk about BTS that way
I [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] about
you dude you could be dying tomorrow
they would spit in your face and be a
music video over your dead body all
right they don't care about you like
that you care about them more than they
care about you
shoutout to BTS I love you guys I don't
know any of their music but their musics
[ __ ] catchy I don't know any of their
music if you hear it's catchy as [ __ ]
though like I'm not I'm not knocking on
that [ __ ] like for me it sounds generic
but like all pop music sounds
Eric to me however it's all very fun
it's like fun music I guess I mean I
missed the kpop music of like early
2000s oh we I mean we everybody they're
gonna say that when they're [ __ ] like
40 years old this [ __ ] and everybody's
it just goes down the line oh man
they're like the kpop music now has
nothing on kpop like well that's how I
feel too
give us a kpop song right now and using
one right now I don't know I'm missing
candy by h.o.t late 90s maybe candy was
late 1990s late 90s but that like that
music was iconic the stuff now is like I
mean it's forgettable
it's unless you're condom style yeah I
mean shoutouts aside my twin brothers
thank you so much for putting you on the
map for putting me on the [ __ ] map
whoa there was this dude remember
[ __ ] Larry front desk at the front
desk big ass big Harry yeah front desk
Larry this [ __ ] remind you he
wasn't trying to be offensive or
anything I might have told a story
before but this dude comes up and I'm
we're living at this place called the
talmadge in k-town and I walk up and he
goes like yo Dave this is how he talks
by the way yeah what's up Dave y'all
congratulations on the Billboard I'm
like Larry I'm not on a billboard he
goes no you owned a billboard outside on
Wilshire like Larry I'm not on a
billboard he goes nah check it your face
is on a billboard and I go outside his
[ __ ] side with the soju bottle and
I'm like this [ __ ] dude he
thought he thought side was me which
arguably I don't blame him for it yeah
cuz back then I really did look like him
yeah like we look like [ __ ] twins I
don't look like him anymore man I'm
[ __ ] did you change you get a
facelift oh very much so very much so
unless kooky now I like saying that work
as I can say it it's like the Asian
person n-word [ __ ] I'll say - as much as
I want I liked you in the movie by the
way uh-huh
thank you very much it was yeah about
two three three years ago four years ago
how long ago was that now what was that
two years ago oh looks like two years
ago man feels like ages ago though it
does feel like ages ago I mean how do
you feel like if you got offered a role
that maybe they'd invite what you
morally would you too
still take it that didn't fight with me
morally I mean I get roles like that all
the time still and I still go an
audition for it like what give me an
example um uh maybe not so much that I
know it doesn't vibe with me morally it
just doesn't feel like it's my story to
tell
per se like what you're supposed to play
what like a like a slave or some [ __ ] no
like I get like I get lesbian roles all
the time and I I mean I could obviously
play a lesbian like there's no like
there's no character factor that like
isn't you know or like there's no
character factor whereas like yeah that
specifically makes you a lesbian as
opposed to like if you go in for some
kind of ethnic role where it's like you
specifically need to be Asian but yeah I
get i get asian lesbian roles all the
time
dude all the actual no it's not my
agents fault it's every lake because
shows are pushing diversity so much now
that it's not about the story it's about
just check anymore I'm checking the
boxes off so it's like oh let's get like
either an Asian or a Latin ex lesbian
and then we can kill two birds with one
stone and be like hey look but like if
you look at the writing there's no there
there's nothing to do with the actual
story of being either a colored person
or LGBTQ what was the story based around
that or is that person just happened to
be a lesbian person in the script
majority of the time it they just
happened to be a person the script which
like you know well that makes more sense
me like I'll go in for that but there
have been a couple where it's like
there's um like one of the characters
she like it it is built in her identity
and like there was this like one episode
where she has to come out to her parents
because she is struggling with an
ex-girlfriend who's getting married to
another girl and like it just built up
it was just like a lot of emotional
build-up of like her finally coming out
to her parents and I'm just like I don't
feel like I can truthfully tell that
story like it's not my story to tell
like I would feel because I know it's my
job as an actor because here's my take
on that and I think that's very odd
because you are an actress mm-hmm so
it's your job in your doodle
to figure that out yeah right so for you
to be in a position or just any actor to
go it's I understand what it's like
technically driven right like you're not
gonna put Scarlett Johansson as a
[ __ ] little Japanese woman named
Michiko in Japan and we're all supposed
to be like now yes she gets it right I
think there's but in terms of playing a
role that's the race doesn't really
matter so much I mean cuz you're a woman
and you can play a woman and it would be
your due diligence to to go ahead and
figure out what that experience is to be
in that person's shoes right because
that's that's for any type of role as an
actor right it's like if somebody had if
somebody approached me to be in a role
and they're like hey dude like you have
to play somebody that was like [ __ ] I
don't know physically abused as it will
actually happen well he had to be
somebody who wasn't physically abused as
a kid I would have to talk to a person
that's hasn't been touching yeah like
what what happened with you you never
got hit as a kid tell me what that's
like well I think it's more so because I
do agree as an actor it's our job to
personalize these stories anyway so we
can tell the most honest and truth
truthful portrayal of these characters
and their lives but I think my thing was
more so not to say that I shouldn't or
couldn't I just like I just know that
there are plenty of maybe LGBTQ actors
that like they would love the
opportunity to get to tell that story
because it is kind of therapeutic and
cathartic in a way I don't know I just I
guess maybe I don't
I wouldn't feel morally wrong I just
would love to give lists I would love to
see an opportunity for someone who has
lived that be able to kind of have that
therapeutic that's kind of cool I think
that's really admirable of you but for
me it's like you're an actor yeah I mean
it's my job because somebody is of let's
say like for example right there's like
a Asian role okay and this role is
specifically for somebody who is a
Korean American person mm-hmm but
there's a Chinese American person who's
Asian that's a way better actor than the
Korean American he hasn't lived that
Korean American lifestyle but he takes
on that role better mm-hmm [ __ ] the
Korean guy I'm taking the Chinese dude
I'm talking about me if I was a direct
and I wrote this film you don't have to
be Korean if that Chinese dude
is an Asian guy and he could portray a
Korean person better than my Korean
actor can I'm taking the Korean do now
hmm right so I feel like for acting it's
just a little bit more open it is based
more on that skill set because let's say
necessarily that there and I'm pretty
like this is just me just just playing
the other side just playing devil's
advocate okay okay well yeah it's true
there is somebody who maybe live that
and maybe they could they want to
portray that but what if that person
sucks what if they can't do it right and
then your acting was just that much
better than them should that director be
mindful of oh well we want to keep it in
the sense of authenticity even though
that person is worse actors than you I
mean I honestly don't know how to answer
that because there are roles that I have
wanted to go out for that were like on
the flip side that were LGBTQ and I was
told by my agent that production wants
people who are actually LGBTQ yes and
I'm like well how do they know is it on
their resume like there's no way of
knowing so I've been on both sides like
where I like there is more so than the
role there is like a show or world that
I wanted to be a part of and the role
just happened to be LGBTQ and then I
couldn't go out for it because they're
like no we want someone who actually is
who is gay or identifies as gay and I'm
like there's a hard part about that is
that if you take this whole thing into
account and if I as let's say for me as
an actor right I go into this role and
then I see I see that somebody took a
role that I really wanted and I felt
like I had the personal life story for
it and if I sit there and I say to
myself well what does that [ __ ]
person know about this this and this
life I actually lived through what makes
them better like it just it's just too
hard for me like if I even think that
stuff though there was a role that I was
going for that was literally an Asian
dude that was a pastor that [ __ ]
sings R&B music and I didn't get it and
I was like who the [ __ ] out this [ __ ]
like let me know who the [ __ ] who's this
guy who the [ __ ] is the Asian guy kid
that can do this [ __ ] he's supposed to
be really goofy very awkward large big
guy and I'm like [ __ ] this you know but
if I sat around thinking about that and
this probably just because whoever
audition for it was better than me yeah
he probably didn't have to live that
authentic lifestyle whatever but he was
better than me
I mean I'm like one of the best exam
apples I mean and I remind myself with
this anytime like I feel a little uneasy
cuz like yeah there's like plenty of
roles where I've gone out for Chinese
American and obviously I'm not Chinese I
don't really know tons about like
Chinese family dynamic and I I'm not
gonna lie I have felt a little like
weird about going in because I'm like I
feel like this should be actually a
Chinese American actor but like yeah I
think perfect example would be someone
like Randall Park who you know in fresh
off the boat like it's not about a
Korean immigrated father it's about a
Chinese about that even he's just great
at it even see mu he's playing a Korean
kid is he on oh yeah I know on Kim's
convenience Kim's convene yes right and
it's not a big [ __ ] deal like if he
if he fits the role and he's doing a
good job and my thing right now is do we
ain't got room to complain like yo if
you're Asian you're Asian you're Asian
and you get in these roles and you
killing it that's cool what will
complain later dude well when that time
comes to be more specific
yeah well we'll be more specific right
now I'll [ __ ] with all Asian fields no
matter how trashy and terrible they are
like I'm over here on Twitter like Tam
dude
so go buy those tickets yeah and inside
I'm like that movie I didn't like it
like you know as an actor I think that's
going back to the whole like we kind of
have to just take what we can get right
now because there aren't enough things
where we can afford to be very picky and
very sick because I know what my dollars
do I know the influence of what my
dollars do right but if somebody were to
ask me did I like the film I'll tell
them I didn't like it did you go bite
yeah I [ __ ] bought a goddamn ticket I
bought [ __ ] crazy rich Asians I
bought a ticket to bed
right wasn't my cup of tea I don't like
rom-coms like that so for me no matter
what film it was it was a rom-com I
already have a just a negative
disposition towards it because I just
it's not my [ __ ] yeah still bought the
[ __ ] ticket didn't go see it in
theatres I didn't see the theater you
sat on a plane yeah but still bought a
ticket though no that's great gold and
open wheat [ __ ] I still did it you know
what I'm saying went online pop one
purchase it didn't go I mean I still did
your duty exactly so I understand what
what I'm supposed to do and what what
helps out right but I'm also allowed as
an individual
have an opinion about it because at the
end of day if we want to be on a level
playing field then you should be should
be want to be judged on a level playing
field - yeah right because the film is
still a film TV shows are still a TV
show people are allowed to like it or
dislike it no matter what right like if
we put out our own art out there and
somebody of our own communities like
that's not great assignment cool is what
it is you didn't [ __ ] like it loser
that's your opinion yeah it's your
opinion you're allowed to have it go die
you know that's that's all you have to
do yeah I tell people to die all the
time yeah it's all good though I mean I
think like that's it's it's being an
actress's just that growing part process
of like trying to I feel like you have
to just sit down and just rationalize a
lot of things because if not it's gonna
make you go crazy oh yeah absolutely I
mean especially with like all the
emotional work that you have to go
through if it's just one of those things
like anything that's why you see people
a lot of young actors like do you kind
of lose themselves because they're not
doing the work to really know who they
are and so they're not only getting
influenced by all the people that
they're around but they're getting
influenced by a lot of these characters
that they play you know especially
because in in a lot of these shows like
we see shows with kids like who'd Apple
and dapple is that a word dabble in
drugs and or partying and like that just
becomes a reality for them you know and
it's like not them to blame it's just
like that's what they're that's the life
that they're living more daily through
acting than like whatever real life like
if they're not finding people to ground
them or like give them like whatever
kind of stable stable life I guess I
mean I don't know what is typically
stable anymore but yeah I just think
like there's a lot of ways that we are
constantly being triggered or influenced
and this is a cool thing to be angry now
yeah like it's the it's like the hot
[ __ ] that's like the new way it was like
if you're not angry about something then
you're really not living yeah yeah like
you have to be upset about something you
have to be angry you have to be sorry
oops you know about [ __ ] this is a Dave
Chappelle job but it's like you gotta be
[ __ ] angry about [ __ ] oh yeah they
gotta be incensed this art rose but like
that's like if not then you don't care
or you're not a quote-unquote which
everybody loves using this Lord and Lok
or an ally I'm not an ally you know what
I mean yeah yeah and that's that's the
hard part about things is like sometimes
I just don't want to satiate it all
because I don't know anything yeah I
know I mean I guess we're going on a bit
of a tangent like that's been something
that's on my mind a lot lately too is
like I just there's so much going on in
the world and so much to speak about and
almost like it gets very hard to
navigate mmm in it it gets very
overwhelming especially like there's
there are so many things to be angry
about right now there's a lot of things
and yet I think one of the things that I
get more angry about is stuff like the
what's that youtubers name
well Paul is that Logan's brother Jake
that whole marriage to change like I've
never I've not seen anything about it
I've just heard a lot of people talking
about it and the fact that that's what's
you know that's the word of mouth that's
spreading that people are talking about
like that angers me and I like I know I
should be angry I am angry about all the
other things going on but that like
really triggers because I'm just like
why is that your concern that you also
have to realize - mmm not to aid you or
age us you're older like right people
who are talking about that that on
Twitter speed they're young kids like
young kids are gonna talk about [ __ ]
all the time in and and once you for me
that's I'm not even coping with it to me
these are just facts young kids talk
about stupid [ __ ] because I was just
like that and I'm not that far from them
either so like of course I they're gonna
talk about the the hottest influences
other time YouTube right now is like for
us when aim was poppin dude you know
what I mean like that's their [ __ ]
world so
if that's like the hot thing that's
going on in that universe everybody's
gonna [ __ ] be chopping up about that
[ __ ] what you know there be to talk
about on AIM I don't about a you dog you
would be you never went into those
[ __ ] like crazy yeah yeah other life
too yeah but you don't know any of those
people yeah but then that we were about
that [ __ ] though or even ready to pick
calm [ __ ] like that you know what that
is saying that's why what's that put
your pick up and people will rate it see
how hot you were Oh like a real hot or
no I would never do it cuz I knew I get
bashed pre-existed yeah right a pic calm
oh gosh at myspace all this other [ __ ]
like we're not any different from this
younger crowd and I just want old ass
people to understand that you're
arguably worse than they are because if
you even go on Facebook because Facebook
is an old person thing now you listen
these old [ __ ] on Facebook dude
they're worse on these kids rambling
yeah this is rambling for no reason
they're just bunch of idiots so it's
more of like a human thing right it's a
collective hive mind thing like when
something's poppin of course all these
young kids are gonna be talking about it
like you're you have to realize too that
if you were that age you will be doing
the same [ __ ] and you're also expecting
maturity out of kids who are their kids
we can't expect them to be mature about
these we would like to we would love
them to think outside of the box we
would love them to think about just more
important impertinent things in this
world but they're not going to because
they're [ __ ] dumb and hopefully one
day they'll grow out of it is what I'm
praying for
but the problem is I think that what we
see is that sometimes they just don't I
guess so we live in a difference aasaiya
T and I think that progressively I think
this is just becoming the social norm
totally I guess what's different okay
cuz i what i was going to argue it was
that when i was in high school we like
my my friends and I we never talked
about stuff like that that didn't matter
to us ya know I didn't know but also to
you didn't you didn't have twitter you
didn't have yeah and so that was I was I
just kind of like fixed my argument in
my head because I was like I realized
that we weren't exposed to the lives of
people in this way yeah we had our own
versions of it we had the cool kids we
had the cheerleaders we had the jocks
yeah you know what I mean right so I
think for them the reason why I get sad
and a little scared and this is where I
agree with you is that now
it's whatever we experienced times 10
right times [ __ ] 10 hence that show
you for you which I haven't watched yet
but I keep hearing people talk about how
like if they don't have kids yet if they
watch you for you they're not gonna want
to have kids
oh my guess what people keep saying but
I need to watch the show because I
haven't experienced it yet so I'm so
curious now yeah cuz that like if
because and the reason why I bring up
this this there's this argument and like
once again it's a way for us to think
about or rationalize what's going on is
that I just have to understand that this
is just how things are progressing yeah
and then I as an individual the only
thing I can do is when I have kids is
tried to deter them from behaving like
that and that's all I could really do I
mean the norms are definitely different
but I think that's what I mean by like
the overload of what's happening of news
whether it be pop culture news or actual
world news it's just there's so much
that we are exposed to and as it is very
difficult to navigate like when you
think about the to mass shootings that
happened back-to-back but then you know
we also like Toni Morrison passed away
and so then that became like what was
flooding all my news feeds but then it's
like I think yeah absolutely pay our
respects but then I feel like the mass
shootings that happen have already died
down which is like it's this constant
overtake of news that's happening and
it's just scary things Toni Morrison
she's a beloved writer father I don't
I'm just being real love it I mean she
did write a book called beloved a novel
called beloved Galka she's a Pulitzer
Prize winner Nobel Nobel Peace Prize
winner african-american female author
she was 88 yeah she's a very very long
life and has she's just regarded as
being like one of the most prolific
writers for black America
no dope yeah so she like and I I do
believe that I love all the love that's
coming out today cuz like everyone's
been posting like their favorite quotes
from her because she's she's brilliant
mmm never read
about her at all possibly I don't know a
14 year olds in [ __ ] maybe but yeah its
but then it's just like well that's what
happened today so that already kind of
like I'm curious or if like people are
gonna bring their attention back to what
just happened you know not they're over
it and so that until like the next new
news story happens tomorrow and then
it's just like this we're constantly
like you know yeah moving on moving on
moving on because there's just so much
news happening and like it's it it makes
it like it kind of gives me anxiety just
thinking about everything that's
happening and so it's like I don't think
that's how I don't like that's why I
don't know how to speak up for things
because it's constantly moving forward
well yeah I mean people are probably
over except for the people who have were
directly affected
I hear [ __ ] about it anymore people
people are desensitized yes it's so
[ __ ] frequent likes a scary thing
like how 9/11 is stuck in my head it's
it's like it happened yesterday
I can remember the seat that I was in I
can remember everybody in the classroom
how quiet they were and how we watched
this my our our our history teacher mr.
Tabares comes in wheels this [ __ ] car
in this TV so we could all watch just
what happened and everybody was [ __ ]
frightened we thought it was the end of
the [ __ ] yeah we see that happen now
people will be over it in the [ __ ]
yeah and it's just that's just how crazy
things are because like nothing nothing
like in 9/11 I mean the only other thing
like 9/11 that ever really happened that
I remember very clearly was the the
Oklahoma bombing um it was Oklahoma yes
yeah
the Oklahoma zombie yeah yeah and that I
think between that and 9/11 those really
the two main like big things that happen
and then the Columbine shooting hmm so
three the three like big Columbine that
like hit but like they're all like super
spaced out and each kind of carried its
own weight yeah and then now it's like
yeah I think the thing that is the
scariest thing is being desensitized to
everything because it's happening on
such a frequent basis and so I I think
even my concern for myself is because
like even how I deal with my own
personal problems I do tend to numb
things and like just kind of push things
under the rug because I don't want to
deal with it and by not dealing with it
I I have over the years numbed myself to
a lot and like suppressed so much
emotion that I had to go to therapy for
did a lot of work but yeah like with I
feel like I'm scared that the same
things gonna happen with all the news
that's happening and the events that are
happening like I'm I'm self-aware enough
that like there are certain things that
I'm like I feel bad that I don't feel
more heartbroken over this well you do
have anxiety issues huh I do it's like
that's like textbook anxiety [ __ ] yeah I
mean it's it's hard to deal with I think
you're just very like you're an
extremely empathetic human being which
is a great trait in quality to have
you know it's just like where do you
it's just where do you balance out this
part of where you let it take over your
life you know and that's like the hard
part right because sometimes like when
you get into these thoughts you tend to
wallow in them yes and when you wallow
in them nothing really gets done and
that's like the thing that I've learned
to do growing up right it's just like
there are things that I could control
and there's things that I can so if I
always focus on everything that I can't
control it's just gonna be constant
[ __ ] chaos all the time and I only
focus on the things that I can do right
because that's just really the only way
I could affect positive change whether
it's on a small scale like in my
personal life or if it's on a bigger
cell when it comes to the people that's
around me that I could affect right and
when we I think like when you listen to
these things and it's very good to be
aware of this stuff right but now it's
just gonna be for other people some
people feel like I can't really do
anything so they feel helpless or other
people feel like I can't do anything in
my immediate control but I will be
mindful of this and in turn in terms of
being mindful that's where I can affect
change yeah right because he just you
being an individual that has the thought
process to even sit there and think
about that it's actually a really great
quality half because some people just
don't care right and even for me
sometimes I'll be it I may come off as
really insensitive to people but it's
because I'm I grew up trying to be a
comic my whole life this is how I cope
with things I make jokes about it
and that's the best way that I learned
how to deal with stuff is to take
something tragic and make it really
funny right because I can't do anything
to change the fact that something
terrible happened but what I can do is
try to change my perspective on things
that's what I used to do as a kid all
the time right and what people don't
realize about a lot of comics there I
think I think like the saying that
comics are extremely damaged that might
be a little little excessive right but
we just have this ability to I want to
see art stuff yeah and I was a
rationalize it but be able to to spin it
in a positive light because that's
what's within our control yeah right is
to really turn track that's why I like
being a comic versus a musician like
with music it's great it's very soul
satisfying as well but something about
laughter is very very [ __ ] healing
right that's why sometimes I say with
people like when people get chartreuse
[ __ ] [ __ ] angry about [ __ ] about I
say people are extremely morally
selective right so for example they'll
be like don't you dare joke about don't
make [ __ ] are Kelly rape jokes right
I'm like oh but the but you were
laughing at the fact that my dad used to
beat me to a bloody pulp when I was a
kid that's okay so family abuse is okay
but this isn't okay so you're you're
chewing your it's highly morally
selective right because if we unpackaged
everything everything can sound terrible
like when I talk about these stories
about my dad beating my [ __ ] ass to
the point where I couldn't go to school
because I was so bruised and beat up if
I say like that it's terrible all right
but as a comic it's our job to make it
funny right to turn this thing and make
it relatable so you can laugh at it
right so that moral selective ism also
like really bothers me when it comes to
comedy right yeah I understand timing
and place so for example when I was on
Twitter the whole Gilroy Garlic Festival
happened and I put up this really yeah
and then I deleted it because number I
don't know people died I thought this
guy just came and he got taken down so I
made a joke about Tim's famous - so if
I've died it would've been okay all
right but people are people died oh god
take that off right cuz I know my limits
and boundaries has nothing to do with
that the fact that people didn't find it
funny cuz they got a lot of [ __ ]
retweets surprisingly [ __ ]
insensitive bastards okay moral
selectivity but I still took it down
because there are people who lost their
lives and that that individual hurt that
whoever lost those people close to them
whatever that empathetic side that I
have made me want to take it down
because I just put myself in their shoes
yeah so like it's just it's just a weird
thing it is I mean I I think with
everything that is going on I think
that's what has heightened the moral
selectivity yeah yeah selective about
what what affects yeah yeah yeah for
sure I mean but that's I mean going back
to what we were talking about earlier I
think that's again why this year has
been a little bit better for me is
because I am trying to focus on the
things that I can control so like again
I I was definitely drew driven 'he's not
the right word I've directed my like
emotionally directed by how auditions
would go or if I booked or didn't book
jobs and like I I let so much of that
control how I would feel that day yeah
for like a good year and a half two
which is like so emotionally dangerous
yeah but that's why I think this year
I've definitely been like more steady in
terms of like where I'm going what I'm
doing because I'm trying to focus on the
things that I can control which is like
what my like daily disciplines are you
know things like that and creating good
habits for myself and then like I've
even tried to challenge myself you know
whenever I am on set like yeah I want to
do good work but I also want people to
enjoy working together and so I like
I've kind of made it this purse like
this is gonna sound so corny I've kind
of made it this personal mission of mine
to be basically a joy balm on set
because like I mean even on a recent set
that I worked on like people looked so
miserable and like would talk about how
like they can't wait for it to be over
and I'm just like dude this is a
freaking privilege like you don't know
when your next job is gonna be so like I
don't know it just kills me that like
people weren't enjoying themselves so I
was like look at that to like know
you'll be here one day I know and I'm
sure I'm sure I'm sure I might but like
like I mean I guess it's kind of like
the same reason why you know you enjoy
being a comic like I I love laughter and
I love making people laugh as well so
you know I would be on set and it would
bring me personal joy to just like make
people laugh like annoyed of you like
they're just trying to have a bad day
going around being a cornball I like a
man to shut the [ __ ] up right my dog
died yesterday unless you resurrect my
dog you shut the [ __ ] if anything I
think it would have been nice for them
to be like oh yeah I remember when I was
on set like that and like that's how I
was too when it first began but I think
it's like you know I think it's good to
be reminded of like what it felt like to
kind of be in my shoes as opposed to
like we're always me as like a actor
still kind of in the beginning stages of
her career like we're chasing all these
like positions that all these other
people have been after all these years
but like I mean there's still something
they can learn from us to being being
you know why deities its we had this
conversation like I was on this like MTV
digital show and then we were all having
the cast members were having this
conversation about when fans of your
work come up to you and what are those
boundaries that you set right and it's
interesting because one of the one of
the cast members she's just started
using social media recently and her mind
she was thinking like hmm I think I
would love it when people would come up
to me you know cuz I think we were all
at that position where well maybe not so
much for me because like I was just like
what the [ __ ] you know I'm always still
like what the [ __ ] like why are you
coming up to me right not in the sense
that I don't like it or don't appreciate
it it's just weird
it makes me it's for me it's weird
because I feel like I haven't done
anything right so from people yeah so
when somebody comes up to me and says
hey can I take a picture with you it's
not something that's wrong with you
there's something wrong with me because
I'm just like why you want to get
picture with me like I'm [ __ ] nobody
like go take a picture with [ __ ] Tim
with yeah the Tim with Tim or one of the
Thames Bros I mean you know Arnold Fang
and Danny Fang did like you take you
know take a take a picture with them
dude you know so like there's like a lot
of people out there that I maybe it's
because I feel guilty for it a little
bit right hmm and it's funny enough
where I I heard the story from I have a
couple rules it's like if I'm eating my
meal you wait until I'm done eating
because I'm hungry
after that we'll talk we'll take
pictures whatever you [ __ ] want but
let me finish my [ __ ] sandwich right
or if I'm with my if I'm with somebody
like my girlfriend or I'm sorry my
fiancee shut up shut up yeah yeah so for
my fiancee and we're on a date and it's
yours it's so important for you to take
this picture you can [ __ ] wait not
because I don't appreciate what you're
doing is that this person factually is
more important to me than you are so
this time that I have with her is
something that I cherish a lot if I give
you if I save you like for example like
for example there's this kid that came
up to me in Disneyland and he was like
oh like I'm a big fan blah blah I came
all the way from here like I'm never
gonna get this chance like hey man I'm
on a date right now
so I guy I want you to just give me that
space or whatever and he was like nah I
need to take this picture I wanted to
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
and the reason why was because I spoke
to him cordially I gave him a hug a
handshake everything and it wasn't
enough room he needed to take a photo
with me
and I was like bro I just we just had a
quick conversation I hugged you we
embraced each other that's pretty
[ __ ] good and then the fact that your
time is more important than mine doesn't
make sense to me you know and some
people are like wolf to them that's
their one moment I don't give up
[ __ ] your one moment was for us to have
and I'd like you I like you because I
appreciate you but then you just who
some would use telling me that you
appreciate me but you literally treated
me like trash just in that second like
you own me and I'm like wait what
happened I thought you appreciated me
and I thought I appreciated you and I
showed you that same thing back so what
it feels like to me is that I'm getting
slighted even though I'm giving you
everything right but on the other flip
my friend John when he used to work at
Interscope he told me there's one story
that made me feel like trash because he
was like so I was and he was like I was
at Interscope and Will Smith was in the
downstairs lobby and he was talking on
his phone like on some real important
[ __ ] and Will Smith is on the phone and
then John just kind of looks up and he
makes eye contact with Will Smith real
quick right just songs and Papa just bro
[ __ ] you're like oh what's up
well Smith is [ __ ] Will Smith right
he's an actual somebody unlike me he
takes his phone down comes up to me his
hey man would you like a picture shakes
his hand chops it up with him for a
little
it and he goes you have a good day Bella
but then he gets back on his phone call
I'm like dude I'm [ __ ] garbage
because I would have been like don't you
see me on the [ __ ] phone I mean but
Will Smith no matter what stage he is in
his life he always goes out of his way
now maybe it's and then I have to also
think about too in that sense it's like
why I wouldn't do that because I'm not
exactly not an extroverted human being
I'm not an extrovert Yeah right like I
like talking to people
I can talk to people I can do it very
well but I really do like my privacy
which is why I'm not I can't daily vlog
that well I don't tell everything about
my life I only tell stories that I want
to tell but like in that kind of sense I
understand where you're coming from
because we do kind of lose sense of like
what it was like before but to my
defense I can say from the beginning to
the end I've always thought I fell
always felt uncomfortable with people
coming up to me like it's always been
like that so like in the beginning I
wasn't like when people came up and was
like yeah [ __ ] should come up
to me it was more like [ __ ] these
[ __ ] trying to rob me yeah you
know it always felt weird ya know III
think it's still a little strange that
hope if you do come up to me though
don't be afraid I'll always just like
that same dude Disneyland I'm gonna hug
you I'm gonna say thank you very much
but if I'm busy and I say hey can we
take a picture next time just be
respectful of that I'll hug you all kiss
you on your [ __ ] mouth if you want to
use stupid son of a [ __ ] anyways that
being said I think I've had experiences
where I don't I don't care for a picture
because like someone's just gonna brush
you the picture this is actually me like
having met certain people in my life who
I am fans of and I'll connect with them
in a conversation and that's much more
memorable than that's what I quit photo
that's why that's why I'm kind of
surprised but that I mean that could be
an age difference thing too because this
is me speaking as like you know an adult
having met people that I really respect
and then I'll have a really great
conversation with them and then low and
behold I might see them in a few months
like I've run into people multiple times
and then they remember the conversation
yeah they remember me and I remember
them as opposed to like having two
seconds to be because I'm not gonna like
I'm gonna pull up this way remember this
is me we have this picture together
remember
you know but that's what they're trying
to yeah which is like you don't have to
prove anything which I always thought
was odd it's like yo bro like I we had a
conversation and I told you this yeah
and you know Muriel was like nice and
nothing should I just take a picture
with them cool so I took the photo with
him but he might in the back of my mind
I was like I'm glad you're happy but I
wish she would have taken the other
option of the conversation in the moment
versus having to take that photo but you
know nothing against to do I completely
understand
like I get it so like I don't tell the
story to trash on the guy I think he was
perfectly fine super sweet very great
dude sure it was just for me it's odd it
might be like a generational gap thing
yeah I mean I think in this day and age
people have absolutely no filter when it
comes to just jumping up on people to
take a photo but yeah I I mean if word
of advice conversations and moments are
much more precious than a photo that
you're gonna maybe post on Twitter
Instagram and it's just gonna be like
involved by the rest of your picture
then you have to scroll forever it's not
even a fan thing to I think it's just
less how people are people want to
record every part of their lives if
there's no video there's no photo than
it didn't have yeah and it's just the
age that we're living in we just we're
just trying to adjust to it and it's
hard for me it really said though is
there someone that you would ever stop
to be like hey can I get a picture if I
see that they're doing something
important
know you even if it's like there's no
like I don't know like top top top
person you're like well I love Dave
Chappelle but if Dave Chappelle was
eating [ __ ] food Dave Chappelle's is
gonna eat his food so if Dave Chappelle
was walking by I would say mr. Chappelle
I shake his [ __ ] in and I'd say
everything I probably wouldn't take a
photo just because I'm not even good at
taking [ __ ] selfies on myself and
after he would leave I'll be like [ __ ] I
should take a photo but maybe in that
type of sense right but that's like Dave
Chappelle it used to be Bill Cosby until
it became a rapist you [ __ ] and then
yeah Michael Jackson if you're still
alive because he did not touch those
kids and then okay we'll go with Dave
Chappelle's and see me live yeah well so
there were people but everybody's a baby
touching a [ __ ] rapist or [ __ ] so god
damn it
would you ever be that guy that like if
you did see Dave Chappelle and say he
was busy would you walk by him and be
like chartreuse no just keep watching
I just imagine that that probably
happens to them all the time you know I
would never I respect their love the man
too much right but everybody's different
you know so like yeah when I think um if
people ever do come up to me it's just a
very it's it makes me feel weird cuz I
just don't feel what the word is like
worthy of it right yeah I want to do
something where I feel worthy of that
type of compliment or praise and I just
feel like I haven't done that yet but at
the same time they're like well who are
you to say how you affect my life
so if they've effect if I've somehow
affected people's life in a positive way
I should be grateful enough to say thank
you
yeah and what I do yeah I do do that the
[ __ ] you're an OG you've been around
yeah man it's kind of weird though it's
very nice though it's very nice that you
in this podcast right well I remember
when I start this podcast people are
like you know what the [ __ ] is this like
where are my videos and [ __ ] you know
but the thing about the podcast and the
reason why I like it a lot is because
there's a certain audience that kind of
grew up with me right yeah and these
10-minute videos aren't long enough for
them sometimes and there's different
perspectives that people need to hear
because a lot of the times when I do
these comic videos I have a very sharp
and harsh stance on things but it's in
the light of comedy yeah all the time so
like do I really believe have to see
half the stuff that I'm saying to a
certain extent yes but within that five
minute video there's an hour
conversation that can be expounded upon
so that's why I love the podcast and
that's what the podcast is well we've
been doing this for an hour in 14
minutes
oops wait Khalif who would you take a
picture with I must know it's my pitch
away everybody dude it's amazing how
many celebrities would you interrupt
though for a picture I enter up to
somebody and he said no oh you did
actually do someone yes john c reilly
Jhansi Oh what do you mean what do you
mean no you say no okay I can't he so I
saw but granted he was with his family
but okay got him as he was like on the
outside of his family cuz he's just
kinda like looking in this guy's looks
kinda
okay that's that's teller - as I came a
big fan I just saw you know stan and
Ollie game-changer for me thank you for
your work may I take a foot it was very
nice as I was saying no I don't even
finish the question yeah so I was like
may I take a photo and he was already
turning me like no but did he even like
acknowledge oh he shook my head okay I
did definitely shake my knee okay so he
acknowledged yeah I wouldn't have done
that though like if I wasn't my family
and then we weren't engaged in anything
and I was just caught staring off into
space and somebody came up to me I
definitely take a photo with them I do
nothing special
yeah somebody if I'm staring off in the
space if somebody comes up and like you
know I appreciate your work you can't
take the photo well my family's over
here ignoring me yeah definitely would
take a photo that's cuz I saw him I was
like am I gonna take a picture why he's
talking to his wife and looks like his
son or a nephew or whatever yeah cool
whatever I'm gonna work on my life I was
like working on audition oh yeah yeah
and then he like just straight off I'm
like oh [ __ ] this is the opportunity
cool I've been here for like 30 minutes
let me just go over there he just said
no I got burned on that he's probably
one of those dudes that's just like he
doesn't really care about attention oh
yeah and then understandable tyka Taika
Waititi he's he's I've met tyga he's a
really nice guy
yeah he's the nice that's the
conversation that we had was just so
overwhelming that I even think about gee
I don't even think about taking pictures
anymore because I have an iPhone 6s and
I'm more embarrassed that it's just not
gonna come and get it yeah and I'm like
I'm gonna be embarrassed if like the
picture doesn't turn out because I don't
be that person be like oh wait hold on
one more like Kendrick Lamar he was so
nice about it three times
oh my god don't worry about it you go
ahead I just wouldn't do it at that
point because like here my phone is just
not the best phone I'm stumbling this is
his speaking voice like his rapping
voice yes yeah I reckon a zero fragrance
I think the last celebrity I even took a
picture with was back in like 2015 no no
no way longer 2011 no was the last
celebrity photo I think I took
like I'm so sorry can I please take a
picture with you Lucas so it was
Pharrell throw real cool for the third
time to last photo I took with the
celebrity was Kevin art now do you like
Kevin Hart he's a nice guy is he yeah
he's he's entourage is scary
who you talk about Nayeem Linh and
[ __ ] knows people are I remember I
worked in the mics I worked an event and
like I guess like Kevin Hart was like
the big a-list or that was supposed to
be present and I just remember his his
entourage they're being such dicks to us
like super me and Kevin Hart wasn't even
around and I feel like if he were they
wouldn't have been as me oh but because
he wasn't around they were like making
all these demands and being like just
huge dicks hmm and I was like it just
was like it was like you're not even
[ __ ] Kevin Hart dude I don't even
know who any of those I think one of
them was like his trainer and yeah he's
too famous to do shitty and gonna do
nothing oh [ __ ] I'm kidding guy he's
buff as hell dude you're gonna die man
well you just train just yeah just train
yup just train well I'm thinking about
Michael B Jordan trainer oh I would stop
Michael B Jordan I would you want
anything
whoa oh really yeah oh she's trying to
get on that [ __ ] Michael B dong dude
what you like huh who isn't me liars
liars so wait so okay
so Kevin Hart's crew was like [ __ ] up
or they were just mean towards me yo
I've heard Kevin Hart himself is nice
but his entourage just they were not
kind people Kevin Hart's a very nice guy
and I think like if you listen to Kevin
Hart on the Joe Rogan podcast where he
talks about kind of like Fame and like
fan interaction like he appreciates fans
too and I'm obviously like I don't even
know what the hell he experiences but
he's like talking about he's taking a
piss and people can we take a picture
like that he wouldn't be surprised those
are like the boundaries that aren't set
and it kind of makes then we become the
[ __ ] yeah it's like hakka mind
sold that I'm asking you to respect my
space and I will do this but just asking
an appropriate setting but no matter
what and any type of sense we're always
the [ __ ] [ __ ] right I tell you
something I get recognized about three
times every two years all right so it
comes out around a lot dudes and I'm
like yo man chill dude
like I'm just happens all the time yeah
but anyways you guys can catch the
genius brain podcasts on Spotify
stitcher and of course iTunes give us
that five stars very important leave in
the comments below about what you guys
think your thoughts have conversations
and remember take us on your route
wherever you go great funny
conversations also I always have to
mention this [ __ ] when I'm talking to my
female friends right and I'm like [ __ ]
you don't you don't do that to other
females all right we have rapport that's
that's what happens all right these
people always do this [ __ ] works like
cuz like I always see this stuff where
if we've been friends for a long time
right you like you little [ __ ] we're
blending right I think that that's a
pass for them to use it constantly with
the people that I talk with like
whispers if like with Geo it's like naw
[ __ ] that's our relationship you
don't get to say that [ __ ] and then you
dumb [ __ ] anyways guys have a lovely
lovely blessed day I don't know which
day this is opening but may the Lord
bless you Pastor David yeah may the Lord
bless you try not to be too chartreuse
and we're yeah and then yeah we're done
though yeah we talked for three more out
no just kidding
Amanda where can they find you Oh at
Sookie styles su ke i est y le s on
Instagram and Twitter and that's pretty
much it but I'm not really super active
so uh horsey was poppin with her you see
are on a movie screen you see her on the
TVs that's right well I don't know when
this is when this episode or this
podcast is mm-hmm
but I will say just please watch
Runaways season three on December 13th
is when it drops on Hulu and you may see
me so there's that mm-hmm she plays a
stir fry cook we're gonna find you you
find me a clean boy after
I was here for a second you talk I bet
that's my thing man every [ __ ] time I
bring him on this bull has so much [ __ ]
to say outside the [ __ ] mic and then
he [ __ ] episode until you say so [ __ ]
I know you guys lied me up in the
comments and [ __ ] uh Cleve boy - man
yeah that's a that's me that's it
all right shall we see y'all next time